We were just talking about this in the break,
all the extracurricular stuff-
Yeah.
We choose to take on
and you have this new cooking show.
Tell us about it.
Well, first of all, it's the most ridiculous thing ever,
because if you do watch the "Today" show
or you know anything about me, you know that I cannot cook.
Like, I can't even boil water or boil an egg.
And every time I go in the kitchen, there's blood.
Like, I'm always stabbing myself.
I once cut myself on a pre-sliced English muffin.
(Drew and audience laughing)
Like, it's pre-sliced.
What am I doing with the knife? Why did that happen?
But for years on the "Today" show because these,
like me and cooking segments has become a recurrent shtick
'cause I'm always saying the wrong thing
and I don't know what I'm doing.
They're always trying to teach me how to cook.
And finally I just said,
"You know what? We could do it.
We could do a little show online
on our streaming channel Peacock-
Yep.
In "Today All Day."
But you have to actually let me cook.
Like, you can't just make it all nice.
Like, Martha Stewart dump this in, dump this in.
Well, who couldn't do that?
I don't know how to chop an onion.
Yeah.
You know, I don't know how much oil to put in the pan.
It's really basic.
So it's called, "Starting From Scratch."
Perfect double entendre.
It is really, really fun.
It's like unintentionally funny, you know?
(Drew laughing)
It's like,
"Hi, I'm Savannah Guthrie.
I can't cook and this is my cooking show."
You know?
(audience laughing)
Okay, well, this is a perfect segue.
We have some questions coming
from some of our favorite chefs to you, Savannah.
Let's see what the first question is.
This is embarrassing.
Hi, Drew and Savannah. It's Anne Burrell here.
Hey, Savannah. I heard that you are learning how to cook.
Hurray! Congratulations.
So, I have a little bit of a question for you.
Maybe a quiz you could say.
The first thing that I teach people when I teach them
how to cook is the term, "Mise En Place."
Drew, do you remember what this means
from when I was on your show before?
A, does it mean "Put in Place" or B, "Mind Your Plate?"
I know this one.
(audience applauding and cheering)
This is the first thing they taught me on the cooking show.
I watched it.
Mise En Place.
And it just means put all the stuff
in little baskets or whatever,
like in cups so that you can then, it's all done.
And I actually think it's really good.
You just measure out all your stuff
and you put it in little cups.
It does make more dishes,
so the lazy side of me doesn't like that,
but it's good especially if you're one of those people
that looks at the recipe over and over again
and Mise En Place.
Let's see if you're right.
The answer is A.
Mise En Place means put in place.
And what that refers to is do all of your prep work
before you start cooking
because it takes the stress out of cooking.
Start there and I bet
you'll have a lot of fun in the kitchen.
Good luck.
Aw. Thanks, Anne.
(audience applauding)
All right. Who is our next question?
Hi, Drew and Savannah.
It's me Geoffrey Zakarian.
So, I commend you first of all for learning to cook.
My question is knives.
It's a really important part of my arsenal
and every chef's arsenal.
I'm gonna ask you a question.
What kind of knife is this mhm?
What do you think?
Is it a serrated knife or paring knife?
That is a serrated knife.
That is the knife that I cut myself
on the pre-sliced English muffin.
I know that knife anywhere.
You know that knife intimately.
Yes.
All right.
Did she get it right, Geoffrey Zakarian?
Amazing.
The answer is, of course it's serrated.
Great for tomatoes and bread,
especially big loaves of bread.
They're uncut and baguettes, crunchy bread.
It's perfect.
Don't use it on steak or chicken.
It tears the meat. It's a big no-no.
But for tomatoes and bread of all sorts, it's perfect.
Cheers to cooking.
(audience applauding and cheering)
Okay, here's another question.
Hey, hey, everybody.
Double R here, Rachel Ray.
So Savannah, I've got another culinary question for you.
So pasta, it's a super quick and easy dish of course,
for anybody to make, especially newbies in the kitchen.
Everybody can do it.
But what do you add to your water
before you drop the pasta in?
And the water should always be at a full rolling boil.
Is it oil, A.
Or B, salt.
Now I'm doubting myself.
(audience applauding)
I know you have to salt the water.
But she said specifically right before the pasta goes in,
what should you put in?
So, maybe you should also put in oil?
I think it's A or B.
Well, if I have to say, then I'm just gonna go with salt
because I know that salt has to be in there.
And the correct answer is?
It's gonna be C.
Salt.
Yeah!
It's only opportunity you get to season the past itself
and a liberal amount of salt.
More than you think you need.
You want that to be similar to seawater.
You should actually taste the water.
Does it have any flavor?
That's how you're flavoring the actual product
you're putting into the water.
Happy cooking, honey.
(audience laughing and applauding)
And we have one more.
Oh.
Yes.
Okay, Drew and Savannah. Here's a good one.
In order to make your pancakes or waffles
nice and light and fluffy,
you do what to the eggs in the recipe?
Well, I mean, I don't know.
You just do Bisquick.
(laughs loudly)
And then you'd crack the eggs
and then water and you stir it.
Okay.
Does he mean whisk them?
All right. Reveal the answer, Bobby.
The answer is you separate the yolks and the whites
and whisk the whites until they're nice and light and fluffy
and fold them into the batter.
Does he think I have three hours to make pancakes?
Bobby, if you think I'm separating eggs
and yolks and whites.
(audience laughing)
Do I look like Julia Child? I can't do that.
Okay. Well, I love your fearlessness
and I love you as a person and we're going to get tattooed.
I cannot wait.
(audience applauding)
And I love you.
I love you.
I love you so much.
I love your bright smile and your big brain
and your good heart and I'm just so lucky to be your friend.
I can't believe it.
I love you so much.
All right, Savannah Guthrie.
(audience applauding)
Thanks, everybody.
Don't miss the "Today" show every morning on NBC
and be sure to check out their Olympic coverage.
I'll be there. We'll be right back.
(upbeat music)